hello everyone and welcome back to the
chessable Masters 2024 we have a very
nice game between ala fua and Dennis
lazovic Dennis lavic played the finals
against Magnus Carlson he lost Magnus
Advanced to the to the Grand Final and
now two of them are playing in the
losers bracket of the final where ala
fuja defeated Yan pishi in the
semi-finals of the losers bracket and
now he faces Dennis lazav for the chance
to face Magnus Carlson in the Grand
Final this is the first game they played
and it's quite a quite a tricky one now
in these games as this is a rapid chest
10 minutes per player plus um 2 seconds
increment of course you will not have uh
a classical uh game type setup where you
know one player has the advantage and
then they nourish it for 50 60 moves
until they win the game here it's more
of a Let's uh trade everything quickly
let's play really quickly and then you
know who whoever is the more precise
player whoever is able to play uh
precise moves the more more you know
quick quickly uh will G gain the upper
hand so it's a a pretty uh tough matchup
for for Dennis although he is an
incredible player you've seen how he
struggled against Magnus because
although he matched Carlson's moves move
by move uh he just took a lot more time
to make them so let's see how he does
against ala and who will face Magnus in
the Grand Final so alza has the wi
pieces and he opens with Pawn to E4 we
have Pawn to E5 Knight F3 Knight to C6
and Bishop to C4 the Italian game is on
the board with we have Bishop to C5 at
the Joko piano and now not everyone's
favorite move but Pawn to D3 the Joko
panimo as we see it uh pretty much all
the time Knight F6 we have H3 and D6 so
pretty standard stuff C3 both players
will go for the usual moves black plays
A6 makes room for Bishop to A7 Knight B
to D2 and Bishop back to A7 so later on
you will not to get a Tempo on that
Bishop while advancing B4 or D4 uh
Bishop back to B3 and now you can if the
bishop gets attacked with something like
Bishop the bishop to E6 you can shift it
over to C2 and keep the Bishops on the
board uh castles and now Knight to F1
going for the standard reshuffling of
the Knight also you will now be able to
counter the dark Square Bishop so if the
bishops get traded off you can even get
a knight to E3 with have Bishop to E6
and all is tugs the bishop back to C2 uh
also uh by playing this you give up the
the control over the D5 Square so then
is goes Pawn to D 5 e captures and now
there is a game where Knight captures
was played but here we have Bishop
captures on D5 and it is now already as
of move 11 that we have a completely new
game so okay Knight to G3 going for
pretty pretty standard setup Rook to E8
preparing Pawn to E4 even better when
the white king is in the center of the
board so ala quickly hides it over to
the king side we have Pawn to E4 uh and
now D captures Knight captures and now
Bishop to F4 now the the bishop is
putting pressure on the C7 Pawn for the
moment it's defended by the queen uh but
if the Queens get traded off the C7 Pawn
could become a Target so that's why
Knight captures and G3 Bishop captures
and Bishop back to B6 to add a Defender
to the C7 Pawn uh we have Rook to E1
offering a rook trade and thenn is
trades we have Rook captures ala
captures with the queen and queen to F6
putting pressure on the Knight on F3 and
now Queen to E2 uh as uh the d8 square
is not covered by anything so you don't
have to worry about Rook to8 the queen
is very nicely placed here and thenis
has to decide whether he wants to
continue with something like King to f8
or G6 or he wants to uh ruin alda's
kingside Pawn structure which he does he
plays Bishop captures on F3 but ala not
ready to call it a day just yet he plays
G captures on F3 he wants the Queens on
the board uh G6 and The Rook to E1 so
Alesa claims the E file for himself and
then he claims the D file for his Rook
uh King King to G2 we have King to G7
and now Bishop to
A4 uh putting pressure on the Knight and
now Rook to D7 now Rook to D7 and this
is what I meant in the beginning of the
video although uh you could easily have
this uh being played in a serious
classical game these are really really
good moves played by both of them uh
Rook to D7 is uh well imprecision to to
call call it like that at the least
because uh you can easily win a pawn
here now the question is uh even if you
even if you spotted this in a Blitz game
in a well it's a rapid game but now alza
is below below 4 minutes and Dennis is
already down to two minutes uh you will
play Bishop captures and C6 I'll just
show it because it's a lot of fun how
you can win a pawn bishop captures Queen
captures on C6 and now Queen to E8 and
now uh if you don't want to have this uh
Queen on E8 when Bishop to E5 lands of
course you will offer a queen trade so
Rook to to D3 now you're offering a
queen trade while attacking that F3 Pawn
but now Bishop to E5 with check Pawn to
F6 is the only move otherwise you just
get destroyed so Pawn to F6 and now
Queen captures and C6 Pawn captures and
look at this bishop captures and C7
that's how you win a pawn it's so crazy
of course you don't uh see that in you
know with minutes on the clock but um
it's uh really impressive stuff Rook
captures on C7 and yes the the black
Rook would get the second rank go after
the B2 pawn and white would have to
decide whether to go for Pawn to B4 and
give up the A2 Pawn or something like
captures and C6 captures and B2 captures
on A6 and white would be up two pawns
it's uh probably uh too much to ask if
you know you would be able to keep both
of them but even if one gets uh picked
up you will still have the other one to
to push for the win uh but even if uh
you see this it's hard to say if if if
it's you know good winning chances or
you prefer to keep everything on the
board so uh Queen to E8 here by Ala Rook
to d8 chasing the queen back we have
Queen to E4 and again repeating Rook to
D7 the idea behind this weird Rook to D7
move is that he wants to play Rook to E7
and trade off Rooks but Bishop captures
on C6 still a possibility however Bishop
to H4 by Ala now trying to trying to
bait G5 to play Queen to G4 uh but we
have Queen to F5 offering a queen trade
and now ala says all right I don't have
anything better I will m up your Pawn
structure on the king side and queen
side both so he plays Queen captures on
F5 G captures and Bishop captures on C6
B captures now alza with a set of
doubled pawns but to Dennis with two
sets of doubled pawns uh Bishop to G5
now reshuffling the bishop over to F4 to
again put pressure on C7 Pawn to F6 and
Bishop to F4 we have King to F7 uh and
King to F1 so objectively it's a pretty
equal position uh maybe a little bit
easier to play for Al Isa but still with
the bishop on B6 it's hard to take
advantage of those doubled pawns uh Rook
to D3 going after d F3 Pawn King to E2
and now Rook back to d8 you don't have a
way of keeping a rook here so Rook to d8
and now Rook to D1 alza even offers
um a trade of Rooks it's hard to say if
he uh realized the what was happening
here but probably he did otherwise you
just don't offer the F2 Pawn for the C7
Pawn uh but then he St the bait Rook
captures on D1 King captures and now uh
and interestingly ala had 40 seconds on
the clock here Danny said only 8 seconds
on the clock he played Bishop captures
on F2 well a a good move it's just not a
good move at the moment first you should
improve the position of your king like
King to E6 and after King to E2 King to
D5 and uh if you look at this position
for example King to D3 black can play
whatever black can play Pawn to C5
threaten Pawn to C4 if Pawn to C4 check
then you go back and there's no way for
the white king to advance any further uh
however uh Dennis uh decided to capture
the pawn on F2 he thought okay I'll
capture the the double F Pawn Al will
capture the Double C Pawn I mean nothing
really changes we're just trading pawns
here uh but that could not be further
from the truth Rook uh Bishop captur on
F2 was played Bishop captur on C7 and
now look at the difference King to E6
but now King to E2 ala advances with the
king with Tempo huge difference then
with the position that we've discussed
uh Bishop does go back King already
comes to D3 okay we have King to D5 uh
but now Pawn to B4 chases away the
bishop and after the bishop moves now
even Pawn to C4 with check so you can
see how this position where the pawns
are controlling everything and the
bishop controlling the dark squares uh
it's uh much much different than the one
where the black pawn was on C5 and the
white King was completely CAU off from
entering the game at least via the
center of the board uh so King to E6 uh
King to C3 now ala says all right your
Pawn on A6 is stuck on a light Square
I'm just going to bring my king over
here and take the pawn and you have
really nothing to do here I have my
pawns and light squares you have a dark
Square Bishop this is uh now winning for
me okay Bishop to E1 with check King to
B3 King to D7 attacking the bishop but
really just gaining Tempe to shift the
king over to the queen side Bishop to F4
and King to C8 we have Bishop to E3 uh
and now a bishop to G3 uh Pawn to A4
grabbing more space here King to B7 and
now Pawn to B5 and if you really want to
try and hold this you do anything but
capture on B5 but Dennis decided that it
would be easier to hold uh with the
pawns traded off but again he did play
all of all of the moves uh you know from
from 10 moves ago to the rest of the
game with like 5 seconds on the clock he
was playing an increment so he traded
everything captures captures captures
captures but now alza has a pass pawn
and with the bishop nicely complimenting
it there's no way for the black king to
get near that pawn and also the dark
Square Bishop pretty helpless against
the pawn on a light Square so King C7
King to C4 we have King to D6 and now
Bishop to C5 with check King E6 Now Pawn
to B6 okay King goes back you want to
stop that Pawn King to D5 now Bishop to
F4 and Bishop to D4 going after the F6
pawn bishop G5 defending and Bishop to
C5 here then it's repeated with Bishop
to F4 uh but now uh well there are quite
a few moves that you could use to win
this game but uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find the one that ala
used uh it really is the nicest one uh
while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the cleanest way to win the game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to B7 that's the move
and the reason for it is that the black
king cannot stop it and it doesn't
matter that the bishop covers the
queening square H because okay we could
take the long route let's say you just
uh do nothing you you just try to grab
hold of this diagonal you will easily
outmaneuver the bishop Bishop to B6 and
okay now once all of the useless moves
are you know depleted let's say Pawn to
F4 now you will play Bishop to C5 and
there's really nothing if you go King to
C7 then you just give a check trade
Bishops give up the pawn and then use
your king to pick up all the other pawns
and if black tries wasting more time
then Bishop to D4 and now you have to do
something Bishop to C7 and Bishop to E5
and that's pretty much it you uh you
either trade or you don't doesn't really
matter you will capture here and then
you will just gobble up all of the pawns
uh and that's it you will put a king on
G7 and Advance your F Pawn to Victory
that's simple as that so then it's tried
King to C7 instead but now comes ala's
real punch line and that is Bishop to D6
check he's he temporarily sacrifices is
a bishop to temporarily sacrifice the
queen in order to gain momentum on the
king side Bishop captures with have B8
with Queen comes with check of course
King captures King captures and now it's
a simple win you will just take
everything and that's pretty much it
King to B7 uh we have King to E6 King to
C6 and now ala starts gobbling up the
pawns King to D6 King captures on F6 and
he was in this position on move 60 that
Dennis lazovic resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
for those of you who are maybe new to
chess the reason for that is that once
you play a move King to G7 will be
played or even F4 you don't even have to
rush it after King to E8 you will play
King to G7 and now with the King
guarding these three squares it's merely
a matter of advancing the pass Pawn to
Victory that's it King D7 F5 there's no
way to stop the pawn all of these
squares are defended and it's just uh
going to become a queen and that's it so
really a fine uh game by both of them
and you've seen that Dennis can really
play with with the best of them in in
quicker time format and it all it really
all came down to this moment where
Dennis decided to uh well trade trade uh
these two pawns uh prematurely when it
was really time to just improve the
position of your king so sometimes in
your in your own games you can also you
know uh think about that what's the best
way to improve my position and always if
if you can if nothing is Burning uh you
know you you want to make your king as
active as possible not too active that
will few games but as active as you know
uh the position allows it uh so yeah uh
that's how ala won the second game ended
in a draw so alza wins the the losers
bracket finals and will face Magnus
Carson tomorrow uh or rather I believe
it's tomorrow in the grand final of the
uh of the chest Masters 2024 so there
you even have it um ala defeated nepo uh
it was a it was a it was a draw and then
they went into Armageddon a bit less
time so he won the the bidding war and
he was able to to take the win in
Armageddon and then he proceeded to the
losers final where he defeated Dennis
lazovic with one and a half to half and
tomorrow he will face Magnus uh Carlson
in the grand final of the of the chess
bow Masters 2024 so yeah a good attempt
by Dennis he did face Magnus in the
finals he did uh you know wait for the
for the winner of the nepo Ala match but
he could not take down uh the the Great
alera so tomorrow we will you know have
a have a feast ala versus Magnus very
much looking forward to it so once again
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Gard hlan Jeremy anos Carl
Weinberg rajash churi and David
gasparian for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World H so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day